مره اخرى يقاد السودان الى طريق التيه
ويطارد الموت الملاحقين منذ سنوات من اهله
بالخوف والجوع ولم تكتفي الحرب السودانيه
بما تحققه من خراب لتقرر المساهمه بخراب
التعليم عبر ضرباتها من هذه الفتحه في احد
اسوار هذه الجامعه يخرج هؤلاء الطلبه الى
حياه ابخست الحرب منها وهي تنشر القتل في
احياء السودان وشوارعه وصولا الى تلك
الجامعه عبر رصاصه طائشه ازهقت روح واحد
من الطلاب
مدارس وجامعات تاثرت بضربات الحرب ولقيت
ثلاثه تلاميذ مصرعهم نتيجه سقوط قذيفه
بالقرب من منزلهم بمنطقه شرق النيل مستقبل
عام دراسي ينتظر جلوس اكثر من 500 الف
طالب وطالبه لامتحانات الشهاده السودانيه
يثير القلق على مصيره لو استمرت المعارك
لايام
لكن هناك طلب قرروا هجره الكتب والمدارس
بعد ان دمرت منازلهم واخطعت الحرب اهاليهم
على طرق درب النزوح حرب السودان كغيرها من
حروب عاشتها المنطقه تثبت بدورها ان
الاطفال والطلاب يبقون الخاسر الاكبر
ودافع الضريبه الاعلى عندما ينزلق قاده
الدول لحروب داخليه قد لا تبقي ولا تذر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات